ça ne doit pas de cully des saveurs
aussi un engagement que le président ait
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
bonsoir à tout ça nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce lundi 29 novembre
faut-il s'inquiéter de l'apparition du
nouveau variant venus d'afrique du sud
pour l' oms long micron représente un
risque élevé au niveau mondial alerte
également des ministres de la santé des
pays du g7 réunis aujourd'hui en urgence
à londres là pour joe biden en revanche
aucune raison de paniquer une chose est
sûre cette nouvelle souche progresse
dans le monde en france on suspecte 10
cas selon les autorités de santé
certains pays comme la suisse israël ou
encore le maroc ont décidé de fermer
leurs frontières à certains voyageurs
alors la france devrait elle aussi se
barricader pour éviter le pire on est en
vos réactions sur le comté d g d'ayrté
france
c'est une chance de ressusciter l'accord
sur le nucléaire iranien signé en 2015
après cinq mois de pause et négociations
en tout cas repris aujourd'hui à vienne
les enjeux ramener téhéran dans le giron
de l'accord et ouvrir la voie au retour
des états unis la délégation iranienne
se dit prête à ouvrir le dialogue avec
les américains à condition qu'ils lèvent
leurs sanctions économiques
washington a de son côté envoyé aucun
représentant à ces pourparlers
lettre email écoute téléphone les maires
ruraux sont pris d'un sourd en ce moment
à la proche de la présidentielle
certains parlent même de harcèlement
face aux demandes de parrainage dans
notre rubrique qu'en pensent les
français nous irons ce soir la rencontre
de l'un d'entre vous entendrez le
témoignage du maire sans étiquette de
l'ému non loin de metz rubrique à
retrouver dès 21h
[Musique]
faut-il s'inquiéter donc de ce nouveau
variant omicron c'est son nom exige une
action urgente appel lancé ce soir après
une réunion des ministres de la santé
des pays du g7 on retrouve notre
reporter estelle farges devant le
ministère de la santé à paris bonsoir
estelle alors cette réunion d'urgence a
été convoquée par le royaume uni
objectif freiner la diffusion donc de ce
nouveau variant
exactement stéphanie car il est
hautement transmissible et exige une
action urgente conclusion est des
ministres de la santé des pays du g7
dans un communiqué commun à l'issue donc
de cette réunion d'urgence les pays acp
du g7 qui ont salué l' alerte donnée par
l'afrique du sud et je cite le travail
exemplaire fourni à part le pays pour à
détecter ce variant la prochaine réunion
des ministres de la santé à du g7
devraient avoir lieu en décembre
prochain de son côté l' oms a prévenu
que le variant au micron présente un
risque très élevé au niveau mondial et
la liste des pays où l'on détecte ce
variant ne cesse de s'allonger
et justement estelle la france qui
pourrait bien rejoindre cette liste
exactement accardi cas possibles ont été
détectés sur le territoire national
annonce du ministère de la santé les
tests de ses passions sont en cours de
séquençage afin de confirmer ou non une
contamination aux variants au micron
notre noter que ces personnes ont pour
la plupart voyager en afrique australe
ces dernières semaines le variant au
micron a qui est déjà présent en europe
après lé pays bas le royaume uni
l'allemagne ou encore l'italie c'est
l'espagne ce soir qui annonce un premier
cas confirmé sur son territoire merci
estelle farge et ce nouveau variant
découvert donc en afrique du sud
condamne le pays l isolement pour une
durée indéterminée pretoria s'estime
injustement
discriminés à l'heure actuelle de
nombreux voyageurs internationaux sont
bloqués sur le sol sud africain les
précisions de la correspondante verte et
internationale aulas lier à
johannesbourg
des célèbes désolation désespoir
frustration et colère voici le genre
d'émotions éprouvés par la population en
afrique du sud je suis actuellement à
l'aéroport oliver tambo de johannesburg
le principal aéroport international du
pays comme vous pouvez le constater
l'aéroport est pratiquement désert une
situation très différente de celle que
nous avons constatée il ya très peu de
temps alors que des milliers de
personnes arrivées ici tentant
désespérément de prendre place à bord de
n'importe quel vol disponible suite à
l'annoncé concernant la plupart des
voyages internationaux à destination et
en provenance de six états africains
cette annonce a été vécue comme une
surprise des gens qui étaient déjà assis
à bord des avions prêts à décoller ont
dû débarquer des avions qui étaient en
plein vol ont dû faire demi tour et
revenir la situation est telle que des
dizaines de milliers de personnes sont
désormais coincés ici en afrique du sud
des personnes qui ont besoin de se
rapprocher urgemment de leur lieu de
travail ou de leurs familles dans le
même temps tant de personnes dont
beaucoup de sud-africains sont à
l'étranger cherchant désespérément à
regagner le pays bon nombre d'entre eux
n'ont pas eu la possibilité de retrouver
leur pays ces deux dernières années ils
ont des proches sur place dont certains
sont malades ou âgées et qui n'attendent
que de les revoir
je suis dévasté je me sens abandonnée
par mon gouvernement nous nous fions aux
informations sur internet et personne ne
sait ce qui se passe
nous avons été vaccinées trois fois en
bon citoyen nous avons fait tout notre
possible
et maintenant nous ne pouvons pas
rentrer chez nous
je suis dévasté je suis frustré j'ai
pleuré toute la journée j'espérais juste
rejoindre mes enfants et maintenant on
ignore quand on sera capable de repartir
j'ai déjà 76 ans cela me fait peur parce
que finalement je pourrais quitter ce
monde demain sans avoir vu ma famille
les prix des billets d'avion des
derniers vols du pays ont largement
augmenté ainsi que ceux des tests pcr
obligatoire alors que la communauté
internationale est consciente du fait
que cette sud africain sur dix n'ont pas
été vaccinés
cela s'explique en partie par le manque
d'accès aux vaccins dans le pays mais
aussi par l'inquiétude de nombreux
sud-africains à propos des conséquences
à long terme des vaccins sur la santé
les scientifiques locaux se sont
obstinés a expliqué que le nouveau
variant n'était pas d'origine
sud-africaine et insiste sur le fait
qu'il provient d'une autre partie du
monde
or au lieu d'être remerciée pour ses
justifications l'afrique du sud a été
mis sur liste noire
alors faut-il s'inquiéter de
l'apparition de nouveaux variants
faut-il fermer les frontières pour
éviter la propagation de cette souche
inédite de cordes un virus c'est la
question que l'on vous pose ce soir sur
le conte télégramme verte et france
place au décryptage
[Musique]
et pour en parler ce soir j'accueille
sur ce plateau va les rangs de
saint-just membre du bureau exécutif du
r'n bon soir valérie injuste à vos côtés
pour en débattre un vincent chauvet
maire modem d'autun et free philippe
froguel chercheur généticien professeur
également l imperial college de londres
philippe froguel vous le spécialiste on
en a beaucoup parlé ensemble du du
séquençage qu'est ce qu'il a de si
différent
ce variant qui vous fait si peur
est là une trentaine de mutations
différentes du
la chouchou originale de wuhan et il est
vraiment très différent un peu un mix à
2 1 initial et donc ces modifications à
son inquiétante parce que
traîne résistance accent elles peuvent
entre une différence sévérité des
symptômes
apparemment et ses symptômes dont ils
sont peut-être pas si sévère que ça
entre paix sont différents des autres
est en tout cas ça entraîne une
contagiosité extrêmes on dit qu'elle est
cinq fois plus importante que le dk et
ce qui voudrait dire que ça va déferler
sur le monde comme ça a déferlé en une
semaine on à l'afrique du sud je vais
rester un petit peu avec vous parce
qu'on a quand même bien besoin de
comprendre c'est pas vrai que c'est pas
rassurant ce que ce que vous nous dites
vous dites une grande grande
contagiosité mais c'est vrai que les
premiers cas examinés laisse à penser
qu'il ne serait pas si grave je lisais
alain président de l'association
médicale d'afrique du sud les symptômes
étaient différents plus légers que ceux
traités auparavant parlant des nouveaux
patients pas de perdre le goût ni
d'odorat ça veut dire quoi plus
contagieux mais pas nécessairement plus
graves voire peut-être moins graves
alors ce que nous nous attendons depuis
un an et demi c'est le variant qu' il
soit le virus qui soit très contagieux
mais qu'ils soient atténuées et c'est
comme ça que souvent les se termine les
épidémies c'est pas tellement parce que
les gens sont résistants c'est
simplement que le virus change et à la
fin devient très modérée et c'est ça
qu'on attend si c'est le cas c'est une
très très bonne nouvelle parce que
beaucoup de gens sont affectés s'ils
font pas la maladie ça va arrêter la
pandémie dans deux mois et ça ça serait
une très très bonne nouvelle mais on
n'en sait strictement rien aujourd'hui
la population sud-africaine une
population jeune et qu'il faudra savoir
c'est les personnes de 60 ans passant de
10 ans qui contractent même vacciné ce
variant au micron est ce qu'ils sont
malades et ce qu'ils sont à l'hôpital et
skimmer qui sépare le cas très bonne
nouvelle si c'est pas si et là ça il est
aussi voire plus dangereux que le
deltaplane valant par exemple lui il
faudra probablement faire encore une
dose de vaccin est à cette fois ci un
vaccin modifié philippe rangama une
quinzaine de jours pour être fixés sur
la réelle dangerosité
de au micro mikron on ne sait pas c'est
selon alors déjà on a du mal à les
nommer et fichu par ailleurs en soyons
honnête
donc 4 une quinzaine de jours une
quinzaine de jours au micro nos micros
on sera d'abord ce qui se passe là bas
en afrique du sud et puis on sera avec
leca caen qui ont été importés en europe
donc on pourra répondre à la question
est ce que c'est vraiment un danger
majeur ou est-ce que c'est finalement
une chance le le virus atténué qu'on
attendait
donc à prendre des décisions importantes
notamment par rapport à vos
développements ou pas d'un nouveau
vaccin alors on va en parler justement
ces mesures avec nos invités va les
rendre sérieuse vous voyez réagir à ce
que nous disait notre généticien
philippe froguel or c'est vrai que d'un
côté ce soir joe biden nous dit pas de
panique à on ira aux états unis dans
quelques instants le g 7 ans ils nous
disent hautement transmissible attention
actions urgentes s consisté reese trop
facilement au contraire il faut être
précautionneux et prendre les mesures
tant qu'on a on a le temps de le faire
écouter ou moi je suis responsable
politique je n'ai aucune des qualités de
de monsieur je ne sais pas le sujet de
votre émission ce soir c'est la
dangerosité du virus mais aussi la
question des frontières
vous avez tout à fait raison et il ya de
grandes craintes ça peut s'avérer
presque la fin de la pluie des vies où
il ya quand même très grande crainte
alors supposons que les craintes soit
avérée qu'est ce qu'on fait et c'était
ça le sujet en ce qui concerne délai les
frontières je peux je pense d'ailleurs
le sujet est intéressant politiquement
je pense que nous ne devons pas avoir de
tabou et que s'il faut fermer les
frontières il nous faut des fermes et
peut-être faut-il les fermes et
maintenant parce que vous avez parlé
d'un délai de 20 jours pour savoir s'il
était vraiment dangereux ou pas si on
attend 20 jours et qu'il est dangereux
c'est fichu il ya déjà des cas en france
et des cas en belgique à des clans
d'europe le responsable de politiques
qui doivent prendre des décisions qui
est au aux affaires et qui doivent
prendre des décisions hamon change il
devrait vraiment penser aujourd'hui à
fermer les frontières elle peut être
très ferme et intégrale lourds comme
viennent de faire israël ça représente
énormément d'inconvénients
c'est sûr pour les êtres humains pour
les voyageurs et surtout aussi pour la
circulation des marchandises pour
l'économie générale l'économie
européenne dans l'espèce et l'économie
française mais les impératifs de chanter
à mon avis doivent être prioritaires et
s'il faut le faire on le fera et voyez
vous cette question est en réalité très
intéressante sur le plan politique la
maîtrise par la france de ses frontières
on le voit l'art actuel avec la question
des migrants on le voit sur le plan
économique avec tout est question de
concurrence déloyale et là on le voit
sur les impératifs de santé les
frontières de l'union européenne ne
seront jamais fermé l'union européenne
demande comme nous d'ailleurs l'a fait
cet après midi aux pays de ne pas fermer
les frontières
jeune j'ai essayé de voir pourquoi
pourquoi par exemple oms demande cela je
n'ai pas compris n'ont pas donné de
raison est-ce que encore une fois c'est
idéologique un désormais la disparition
des frontières c'est définitif il faut
pas revenir dessus et qu'un pays comme
la france ferme ses frontières ça serait
un retour en arrière attention au retour
en arrière sur le plan idéologique c'est
épouvantable donc la question est en
même temps technique politique est
intéressant sur le plan du fond car je
pense que nous souffrons énormément en
france depuis longtemps de l'absence de
maîtrise de nos frontières comme nous
avons souffert dans le cadre de cette
épidémie de la déliquescence de l'union
européenne dès qu'il s'agit d'un débat
et je veux maintenu que free mais dans
un deuxième temps vincent chauvet
justement c'était intéressant de voir
alors qu'on ne sait pas encore la vraie
dangerosité on en a parlé avec philippe
froguel de de ce nouveau variant parce
que c'est à ce moment là qu'il faut
prendre les décisions politiques vous
seriez aux affaires qu'est-ce que vous
décideriez aujourd'hui est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec vale rente saint-just
tout simplement être à dix qu'à fermer
les frontières comme d'autres l'ont fait
d'ailleurs on leur temps entre semaine
donald trump avait très rapidement
fermé ses frontières notamment au
royaume uni au début de l'épidémie que
faut-il faire bombance au genre de cas
selon vous alors on n'a pas dû lire le
même communiqué avec vale rentrent sains
juste parce que l'om est-ce demande
justement de prendre des actions
radicales et rapide et le g7 demande
aussi à ses membres mais aussi aux
autres pays d'agir rapidement et on voit
qu'il y à déjà certains pays qui ont
réagi en limitant les transports par
avion parfois de manière très brutale
nous l'a vu pour l'afrique du sud du sud
où des avions en vol ont dû revenir de
toute façon ce qui est très clair au
delà du mythe de la frontière c'est
qu'il va falloir réduire les
déplacements
visiblement il y avait déjà une dizaine
de cadres de aux microbes en france et
donc eh bien il faudra réduire les
déplacements par exemple les conseils
municipaux vont de nouveau se réunir en
distanciait l'on va essayer de ne pas
forcément bouger il ya un certain nombre
de réunions
qui sont très fortement déconseillé au
niveau local les voeux les repas des
anciens probablement auront des grandes
difficultés à se tenir et puis il ya des
pays qui ont des déjà prévu que pourra
pas empêcher les gens de se voir pour
noël les familles de se réunir et par
exemple le portugal a déjà annoncé que
après les fêtes de fin d'année et bien
il y aurait de nouveau des mesures de
confinement au portugal donc ce qui est
très clair c'est qu'il faut limiter les
déplacements les déplacements par avion
évidemment les déplacements aussi entre
régions et puis même les déplacements
hors de chez soi pour pouvoir éviter de
se retrouver de se contaminer ses c'est
absolument évident et je pense que ces
mesures vont arriver bientôt en tout cas
les préfets mais de rétablir dans les
portes du masque on a vu un certain
nombre d'annoncés déjà réalisés et puis
dernière chose c'est ce qu'a dit le
président bailly donne d'ailleurs allé
faire le booster allez faire la
troisième dose on voit que dans des pays
très peu vaccinés l'afrique du sud c'est
30% on peut penser aussi à l'inde qui
est très inquiétante beaucoup de pays
aussi l'année moi je vais pas multiplier
tous les thèmes d'un coup on va on va en
parler par
oui il allait bien tout devrait faire
intervenir si parce qu'il est il est
vous avez une étiquette politique du
modem est ce que vous êtes hostile vous
au principe que la france puisse
reprendre le contrôle de ses frontières
dans le cadre de cette épidémie et de
l'arrivée de ce virus moi je suis un
pragmatique c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
caractérise
verte et le pragmatique veut dire que
quand il y à des restrictions à prendre
et même des restrictions de deux dalles
et d'un département à l'autre d'un riche
d'une région à l'autre il convient
d'ajouter les intérieurs de la france et
moi messieurs je vais donner quand même
aussi la parole à philippe froguel
d'abord je voudrais vous faire écouter
parce qu'a eu plusieurs réactions
politiques mais pas que on a posé la
question aux téléspectateurs je voudrais
d'abord vous faire écouter philippe
juvin lui qui se dit aussi pour la
fermeture des frontières
il faut une fermeture des frontières
pour gagner du temps face aux variants
omicron ce n'est pas parfait ça ne
marche pas à tous les coups c'est même
très peureux il faudrait un contrôle
extrêmement dur comme le font les
britanniques voilà philippe qui est
d'accord avec vous voulez rendre
saint-just on va voir quelques réactions
si télégramme les virus n'ont pas besoin
de passeport profond scheer les
frontières il circule par tous les
moyens de transport du vin de
marchandises légaux et illégaux il est
donc de toute façon impossible
de supprimer tout transport entre les
pays ça c'est alain qui nous lie coco
déjà trop tard ça fait au moins déjà une
semaine que le variant sur le territoire
européen alors là je me tourne vers
philippe froguel un coco qui dit aussi
comme lors de la première souche les
citoyens devront payer de même la
compétence de certains philippe froguel
je vous demande évidemment pas de vous
propose vous prononcer sur des
propositions politiques mais qu'en pense
le généticien vous êtes est-ce que ça y
est c'est déjà trop tard pour vous
est-ce que c'est plié allons père louis
c'est plié
c'est à dire que le virus
mikron va remplacer le delta très
probablement entre maintenant et la fin
janvier est-ce qu'on peut le retarder
oui on peut le regarder en je ne sais
pas si on peut bloquer les frontières
mais on peut les contrôler et en france
il suffit d'avoir voyagé est allé à
roissy ou orly pour savoir que et ça
étonne tout le monde d'ailleurs les
contrôles sont extrêmement faible voire
totalement absents et qu'on n'a jamais
réussi à mettre en place un vrai
contrôle aux frontières en tout cas
aérienne et quand ou dans les ports donc
ça on l'a jamais vraiment vraiment fait
en france et c'est dommage parce que la
façon dont ça c'est fait pour l'alpha
c'est-à-dire leur langue là et puis
ensuite pour l'indien le delta est
toujours été même chose il ya eu des
passages
petit passage de jean calvé dans
différentes parties de la france et là
il ya eu des kloster temps qu'ils
étaient localisés s'est rien passé par
exemple pour le delta le 19 juin c'est
la première fois que nous on a trouvé
des invariants delta dans les hauts de
france avant il y avait zéro mais à
partir du moment où ça s'est généralisé
ça a explosé parce qu'il ya une
congruence des des différents clusters
et l'a fait exploser puisqu'à la mi
juillet il était plus que majoritaire le
delta ce que je veux dire c'est que le
contrôle des frontières est un mois et
bien avec les masques avec vos proches
est un des moyens qui va permettre de
ralentir et pourquoi il faut ralentir
parce qu'on est en pleine cinquième
vague ce que disait le bras monsieur mer
de la côte est désert voilà excusez moi
c'est c'est pas le micro c'est le delta
aujourd'hui en lutte entre le delta est
donc à chaque jour sa lutte aujourd'hui
en vue de contrôler delta qui augmente
tous les jours et ensuite on pourra
essayer de ralentir parce que le pire
serait d'avoir deux vagues en même temps
à la vague delta et puis la vague de
l'eau micron re ya entendu rssil au
micro et dangereux sinon ça ferait le
bénédiction mais
avant de parvenir à vérifier sur 29 à
l'évent de saint-just c'est vrai que la
russie a interdit les vols en provenance
d'afrique du sud est pas les seuls à la
suisse également les états unis ferment
leurs frontières aux voyageurs en
provenance d'afrique mais ne ferme pas
les frontières on va aller à washington
dans quelques secondes
l'europe est laxiste pour vous c'est
vrai que tient il à raison un philippe
froguel et les contrôles n'ont jamais
été d'une rigueur absolue aux frontières
européennes alors que qui a voyagé c'est
que c'est souvent beaucoup plus sévères
quand on va ailleurs je retiens ce que
vous avez dit moi j'ai un crimine la
france pour la change de contrôle dans
les airs pas et n'y a jamais eu de
volonté politique de faire vraiment des
contrôles à l'arrivée dans les grands
aéroports français et je pense que ça a
nui beaucoup à la population française
mais moi je c'est vrai que tout ça me
donne à penser et à parler du rôle de de
l'union européenne en réalité je crois
que si nous n'avons pas réussi depuis le
début de 2020 a résisté vraiment à cette
épidémie c'est le résultat
de ce que nous avons fait un peu de
notre pays depuis une cinquantaine
d'années notamment sa pose la question
de la désindustrialisation de la france
on l'a bien vu au début nous n'avions
plus aucun masque nous n'avions plus de
moyens de contrôle de moyens de test
tous les médicaments sont fabriqués hors
de france nous ne sommes nous avons vu
que nous n'étions pas du tout armé pour
faire face rapidement et efficacement à
une telle crise je laisse à penser pour
les autres crises nous même pas
sanitaire mais éventuellement
bactériologique star à qui pourrait
arriver et ça c'est le résultat la
politique industrielle
de du rôle de l'état de l'état stratège
de du territoire depuis des années des
années sous la pression de l'union
européenne
j'ai parlé des questions de migrations
et des questions économiques
c'est un tout et nous plaidons que pour
un grand nombre de sujets et notamment
de façon obligatoire on est obligé de le
faire à l'heure actuelle pour toutes les
questions sanitaires qui sont
primordiales pour nos compatriotes
primordial les primordial pour moi les
questions de santé évidemment pour nos
compatriotes la france reprenne au moins
pour un très long laps de temps le
contrôle de ses frontières on va aller
justement aux états unis on va vous
laisser la parole évidemment un vincent
chauvet répondre mais où aller aux états
unis qui était connu pour être plutôt
protectionnistes on a vu donald trump
fermer ses frontières assez rapidement
je le répète à en ce début d'épidémie
thomas bonnet vous êtes en direct de
washington notre correspondant sur place
comment a réagi joe biden à l'avènement
de nouveaux variants menaçant
et bien dès qu'il ya eu une annonce de
l'émergence de ce variant omicron
l'administration de joe biden a décidé
d'interdire les voyageurs en provenance
de huit pays d'afrique australe l'idée
pour le locataire de la maison blanche
comme il l'a détaillé il y à quelques
instants ces deux gagnez du temps parce
qu'il sait que tôt ou tard ce variant le
mikron sera présent sur le territoire
américain alors pour l'heure il n'y a
aucun cas officiel de ce variant sur le
territoire des etats-unis mais on sait
qu'il ya d'ores et déjà des cas qui ont
été détectés au canada par exemple alors
dans sa conférence aujourd'hui joe biden
a appelé à la retenue malgré le fait
qu'il y ait des inquiétudes autour de ce
variant il ne faut pas céder à la
panique écoutez le
ce variant est une source d'inquiétude
il n'y a pas de raison de paniquer nous
disposons du meilleur vaccin au monde
des meilleurs médicaments des meilleurs
scientifiques et nous en apprenons
chaque jour davantage nous combattrons
ce variant par des actions scientifiques
et que des rhinites et avec rapidité et
non dans le chaos et la confusion ce
pays marquer un seul alors pour lutter
contre l'émergence de ce variant mais
aussi contre le variant delta joe biden
a de nouveau appelé à la vaccination il
a également appelé les américains à
recourir à cette troisième dose cette
dose de rappel pour tous les américains
de plus de 18 ans il a également appelé
la population à porter le masque en
intérieur dans la mesure du possible il
a expliqué qu'il n'y aurait pas de
nouvelles restrictions de voyages ce qui
fait d'ailleurs débat pourquoi ces pays
d'afrique australe sont concernés par
ces interdictions et pas d'autres pays
où des cas de ce variant au micro-ondes
était à détecter c'est la question qui a
été posée à la porte parole de la maison
blanche qui a eu du mal à expliquer les
raisons de cette décision donc
d'interdire les voyages seulement pour
ses pays d'afrique donc pas de
confinement à prévoir pour l'heure selon
les mots de joe biden qui détaillera
jeudi à la politique contre le commis 19
qu'il souhaite mettre en place pour
cette période hivernale il est entouré
on s'est toujours du docteur anthony
fochi qui ce dernier a déclaré ce
week-end et qu'il fallait peut-être
apprendre à vivre avec le virus parce
qu'il a émis quelques doutes sur le fait
qu'il soit possible d'éradiquer de
manière durable et définitive ce virus
ducobu de 19 merci à thomas bonnet en
direct de washington faire passer par
vincent chauvet justement sur cette
forme de discrimination envers les pays
africains l'afrique australe afrique du
sud vous vous partagez ce la vie
d'ailleurs de l'onu qui
invite à ne pas isoler et punir ce pays
qui lui même d'ailleurs ce se trouve un
petit peu en position d'injustice
invitent-ils
c'est vrai que l'afrique du sud a été
relativement exemplaire dans l' alerte
qu'elle a lancée avec le séquençage de
ce nouveau variant qui vient peut-être
d'afrique du sud qui vient peut-être
d'ailleurs et se retrouve du coup un peu
mis à l'index mais c'est peut-être mieux
que la situation de départ où on sait
que la chine n'a pas forcément été
complètement transparente sur les
informations données ensuite les
responsabilités sont probablement
multiples mais si on regarde par exemple
la grande bretagne qui a convoqué cette
réunion du g7 elle a quitté l'union
européenne à peu près au moment du début
du coc vite ça ne l'a pas immunisé
contre les vagues épidémiques donc il
faut il faut voir aussi que le vaccin
français arrivent j'étais moi-même dans
l' usine sanofi en région parisienne qui
est en train de fabriquer le vaccin qui
servira de troisième dose que l'union
européenne est quand même un des
continents les plus vaccinée encore que
il faut regarder entre entre les pays le
risque je disais tout à l'heure d'être
peut vacciner c'est qu'on soit un
incubateur à rien six personnes est
vaccinée le virus se répand but et puis
on a ces mutations ces variants espérons
d'ailleurs qu'on arrive rapidement à une
variante oméga la dernière lettre de
l'alphabet grec ce qui voudra dire
peut-être qu'il ya plus de mutation sera
ensuite possible mais sans plaisanter en
tout cas l'important et j'essaie
aujourd'hui ce petit club hayden c'est
d'avoir cette troisième dose qu'ils
puissent un peu protégés et puis de
ralentir la règle parce qu'on le sait la
difficulté c'est la saturation des
hôpitaux aujourd'hui nos hôpitaux comme
le disait le professeur froguel il a
raison commence à être un peu rempli par
le variant delta si on prend deux vagues
ensemble à ce moment là ça va être très
difficile pour des personnels
hospitaliers qui sont déjà très éprouvé
par deux ans est quasiment de lutte
contre l'épidémie et donc il faut tout
faire absolument tout et sans aucune
idéologie mais par vraiment l'avis des
scientifiques et par pragmatisme et
suivre ce que dit l'om est c'est à dire
et bien essayé de freiner au maximum
ce variant conti philippe ingall on a
entendu donc oui comme le dit vincent
chauve et un job et d'un appel à la
vaccination et enfin huit mois à ce que
cette vaccination ce vaccin ce qu'il est
vraiment efficace le sait-on contre le
fameux nouveau variant au micro omicron
on sait absolument partout ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que aujourd'hui on a une
cinquième vague de delta il est efficace
contre le delta et et qu'il faut faire
la troisième dose parce que ceux qui ont
été vaccinés il ya plus de six mois et
bien leur taux d'anticorps est en baisse
donc ça c'est le le danger immédiat
ensuite on peut imaginer mais c'est pas
sûr que si on a beaucoup d'anti corps
même si le micro entraîne une certaine
résistance et bien ça soit quand même
efficace
puisque modern a dit par exemple elles
augmenté la dose du delta du vaccin
actuel qui serait peut-être efficace
donc une question de dose ça paraît
absolument est logique ensuite on verra
aujourd'hui on est au jour le jour
simplement en france on est un peu en
retard par rapport aux autres sur le
dépistage du virus
je suis vraiment désolé de le dire
quand je dis ça en accuse de faire de la
propagande antigouvernementale mais je
remarque depuis un an et demi on n'a
fait aucun progrès il faut toujours à un
mois en gros on pourra faire des
diagnostics de variants en france
le dépistage par pcr et il a fallu un
mois et demi pour le mettre en place
contre le delta est là en angleterre
depuis aujourd'hui il est en place il ya
un test qui est en place et leur en
france le gouvernement est là peut-être
parler demain pour dire ce qu'il faut
faire mais on est heureux
d'ailleurs vous le savez c'est pas ce
que je dis est pas discutable un partout
en europe on a des cas avérés et prouvés
en france on a des cas probables il faut
bien qu'il ya quelque chose qui va pas
dans le dépistage pour ce qu'on aime
bien les gens montés piste mal et ça
c'est la même chose depuis 18 mois on
peut peut-être se poser la question
pourquoi en tout cas c'est comme ça va
les rendre sa juste vous qui attend et
politique c'est vrai que philippe
froguel on la vit depuis le début de
cette épidémie nous parle de séquençage
qu'il fait très bien à lille parce qu'il
est aussi entre l'université de londres
enfin comment ça se fait qu'on fasse
aucun problème au progrès sur ce thème
jeux jeux enfin je parle
jeter la pierre du tout aux
scientifiques français et aux
organisations scientifiques mais je
crois je pense que la france est que
l'union européenne se sont mis dans ces
questions qui sont aussi des questions
industrielles scientifiques et
industrielles extrêmement tôt retard moi
je voulais dire une dernière chose que
vous devez t on a parlé d' afrique et de
l'afrique australe à ya une information
qui va frapper moi aujourd'hui c'est que
la chine a décidé d'envoyer en avril
avait un milliard de doses il est clair
qu'il faut absolument aider ces pays la
note sur beaucoup de plans mais
aujourd'hui la tuer je suis un peu
étonné quand même que ni la france même
de façon symbolique ni l'union
européenne ne fâche ya eu 200 millions
doses quand même en afrique par là
il ya alors je sais que les chinois sont
très nombreux et je sais pas c'est pas
le problème enfin la chine est encore à
nouveau en train de prendre la tête
d'une dune d'une aide internationale
ils sont déjà très présent en afrique je
refais pas de de reproches mais encore
une fois nous il n'y a rien eu de
structurel qui était est mis en place
pour aider ce pays sous développés et
notamment en afrique face l'afrique du
sud vous pourriez une population très
jeune j'avais raison puis les conditions
d'habitat qui peuvent être extrêmement
difficile où le virus se répandre à
toute vitesse est très bien s'il n'y a
pas eu de volonté politique
dans cette direction là en fait un peu
moi je dis enfin je tue pas où tu pars
je n'ai pas aux manettes je sais que ça
doit être difficile je suis pas
scientifique non plus on a un peu
l'impression que c'est la politique du
chien crevé au fil de l'eau on voit
arriver des événements on n'a rien prévu
on est démuni et on
on nous fait un peu des cautères sur les
jambes de voix à chaque fois et c'est
comme ça qu'on n'arrive pas en sortir
ouais voilà vincent chauvet le mot de la
fin pour vous parce qu'on arrive déjà à
la fin effectivement sur cette aide
parce qu on a entendu cette annonce will
à la chine qui envoient des millions de
doses bon kovacs en envoyait 200
millions louis milliard deux cents
millions alors on sait que c'est pas
toujours bien des cheminées non plus
faute de moyens sur place votre opinion
là dessus l'union européenne a été un
grand donateur de doses notamment quand
on s'est converti au kaiser
d'astrazeneca aussi peut-être parce que
les européens on voulait un peu moins
mais mais quand même l'union européenne
a été maire de lens mais si dans ce
débat pour sortir sur une pointe
politique peut-être on voit le
rassemblement national défendre l'aide
publique au développement pour les pays
d'afrique c'est peut-être quelque chose
malheur elle a toujours fait on l'a
toujours fait merci en tout cas tous les
toits philippe froguel vincent chauvet
va les rendre sans juste merci d'avoir
été avec nous pour ce décryptage et face
à face un spa entre vous deux merci à
vous et 14,4 du variant au micro on
était à détecter donc aux pays bas
également tous été à des passagers du
même vol parti d'afrique du sud est
arrivé à amsterdam alors que le pays
traverse une vague de contestation
contre les restrictions sanitaires
l'arrivée soudaine de cette nouvelle
souche inquiète le gouvernement ont fait
le point avec sébastien zaba
concordance d'événements les nouvelles
restrictions sanitaires annoncé vendredi
dernier prenne effet au moment où
omicron fait son apparition aux pays bas
comme pour conforter la décision du
gouvernement néerlandais une crème à
mains nues à partir du dimanche 28
novembre l'ensemble des pays bas sera
effectivement fermé entre 17 heures et 5
heures du matin cela concerne les
magasins et des installations sportives
les restaurants les bars et des cinémas
les salons de coiffure et les lieux
d'événements
moins de 48 heures plus tard un avion en
provenance d'afrique du sud atterrissait
à amsterdam avec à son bord 61 passagers
suspectés de porter le variant au micro
ils ont été placés immédiatement en
quarantaine dans un hôtel qu'ovide dès
leur arrivée quatorze d'entre eux ont
finalement été testé positif à la
nouvelle souche du virus deux d'entre
eux se sont échappés de l'établissement
avant d'être interpellé dans un avion en
partance pour l'espagne cette nouvelle
mutation fraîchement arrivée sur le sol
néerlandais est jugée très préoccupante
par l'om est ce lundi vient s'ajouter à
une vague de contamination dans le pays
vingt-deux mille cas du variant delta
ont été détectés ce dimanche les
pays-bas traverse aussi depuis plusieurs
semaines des émeutes contre les
restrictions sanitaires
l'arrivée soudaine du variant omicron
paraît convaincre certains néerlandais
de la nécessité du respect de ces
mesures
j'en ai marre ça commence à faire long
ça serait bien de revenir à la normale
mais je comprends aussi qu'il fallait
faire quelque chose mais cela semble un
peu étrange quand on se rend compte que
beaucoup d'infections ont lieu à la
maison et pas dans un magasin ou dans un
bar c'est là où je me situe je pense
si nous ne voulons pas mourir à notre
âge nous devons le faire ayant un
confinement sérieux des règles nous
devons les suivre
si nous ne le faisons pas nous aurons de
plus gros problèmes
[Musique]
je ne sais pas si les restrictions sont
une réponse proportionnelle en soi mais
il faut faire quelque chose le fait
qu'il n'ait pas plus investi dans les
hôpitaux est un peu louche mais j'ai eu
des discussions avec des amis ils se
sont dits oui mais c'est vraiment
difficile de former des médecins pour
devenir du personnel de soins intensifs
alors peut-être qu'on aurait pu faire
quelque chose en attendant on verra si
c'est efficace
selon leurs premières données les
autorités néerlandaises estime qu mikron
serait plus contagieux que delta le
variant qui pour le moment reste le plus
répandu dans le monde
avec à l'arrivée de cette nouvelle
souche de corne à virus une question se
pose des vaccins actuels peuvent ils
être efficace le développeur du vexin
russe scouts nick v affirme aujourd'hui
que son sérum est en tout cas apte à
neutraliser le vernis au micron les
précisions de notre correspondante à
moscou mejlis d'estrées
alors que le variant au micro n'est
détecté dans de plus en plus de pays
l'institut gamaleya qui a mis au point
le vaccin russe poutine v et sa version
lite à une seule dose estime que ces
deux vaccins sont à même de neutraliser
la nouvelle souche du coc vide la raison
l'efficacité très élevé de ces deux
vaccins pour neutraliser les autres
mutations du virus d'après gehring me
trièves directeur du fonds
d'investissements directs aux russes qui
a financé la production de split migrer
selon l'institut gamaleya spoutnik weill
light neutraliseront omicron parce
qu'ils ont la plus haute efficacité
contre les autres mutations dans le cas
peu probable ou une modification serait
nécessaire nous fournirons quelques
centaines de millions de booster de
pouce n'est qu'au mikron est d'ici le 20
février 2022 pour contrer une éventuelle
propagation du variant omicron en russie
où il n'a pour l'heure pas été détectée
les autorités russes ont décidé de
fermer les frontières du pays aux
ressortissants étrangers en provenance
de plusieurs états africains et d'hong
kong country peskov le porte parole du
kremlin annoncé ce lundi que d'autres
mesures pourraient être mises en place
une fois que l'on saura à quel point
cette mutation est dangereuse et
contagieuse
nous voyons que cette réaction sur les
marchés est extrêmement émotionnelles
elle ne repose pas sur des données
scientifiques car elles ne sont tout
simplement pas encore disponibles bien
sûr c'est une réaction purement
émotionnel
maintenant le monde entier et l'om s
essaie de comprendre à quel point elle
est dangereuse les informations sont
analysés par l'état-major du
gouvernement il a été promptement décidé
d'interdire d'accès en russie des
passagers en provenance de certaines
directions
en ce qui concerne d'autres mesures
possibles cela dépendra des conclusions
qu'auront fait des scientifiques
concernant la contagiosité de la souche
les possibles conséquences et à quel
point les vaccins qui existent déjà
peuvent prévenir la contamination et
l'évolution grave de la maladie
depuis une semaine le nombre de
nouvelles contaminations en russie ce
maintien sous la barre des 35 mille une
évolution encourageante par rapport aux
48 nouveaux cas enregistrés
quotidiennement il y à un mois le nombre
de décès par jour lui continué à
osciller autour de 1200
l'obligation vaccinale pour les
soignants et est à l'origine de la
contestation en guadeloupe depuis une
dizaine de jours c'est une crise
socio-économique qui a appris le dessus
le ministre d outre mer s'est rendu sur
l'île aujourd'hui la rencontre entre
sébastien lecornu et l'intersyndicale a
duré dix minutes à peine montre en main
le ministre a demandé aux représentants
syndicaux de combiner des violences aux
antilles une requête purement et
simplement rejetées par hamé qui
quelques minutes selon lui et puis s'en
va à peine entamé les négociations
prévues ce matin entre le ministre d
outre-mer et l'intersyndicale sont déjà
terminés avant de commencer les
discussions
sébastien lecornu avait posé une
condition préalable la condition du
dialogue c'est la condamnation des
violences par l'ensemble des forces
politiques et syndicales et plus
précisément de tentative de meurtre sur
les policiers et les gendarmes
le ministre d outre mer restent
disponibles pour ces discussions mais
dans ce cadre clair la rencontre censée
apaiser la situation en guadeloupe a
donc tourné court avec les syndicats
depuis quelques jours les antilles sont
le théâtre d'un mouvement de
contestation martiniquais et
guadeloupéens protestent contre le pass
sanitaire la vaccination obligatoire des
soignants mais aussi contre le coût de
la vie une rencontre attendue par des
syndicats dès lors évidemment déçu
l'objectif pour nous c'est d'engager les
négociations est que nous soyons dans un
cadre de négociations et donc je crois
que monsieur le promu ne trompe pas du
tout du tout du tout ces négociations a
aussi eu lieu et où il végète c'est sa
responsabilité sur la situation sur les
jeunes et si vous les élus guadeloupéens
et je crois qu'encore une fois il ya eu
une erreur de casting ce monsieur n'à
aucune sensibilité pour l'outre-mer
l'outre-mer ne l'intéressent pas et je
crois que lorsqu'il a été roi poussé
chevauchera s'était sûrement une erreur
de casting après l'échec des
négociations avec l'intersyndicale
sébastien lecornu rencontre en ce moment
même une délégation d'élus locaux le but
de la manoeuvre tenter d'apaiser une
colère profonde avant de réitérer
l'opération demain mais cette fois du
côté de la martinique
après cinq mois de pause des
négociateurs sur le nucléaire iranien
sont à vienne aujourd'hui objectif
tenter de relancer d'accord conclu entre
téhéran et les puissances mondiales en
2015 une reprise des pourparlers qui
fait réagir yamina benguigui
le palais cauberg un lieu bien connu de
ses diplomates puisque c'est ici que
l'accord nucléaire a été signé c'était
il ya six ans ce lundi les signataires
restant la russie la chine la france
l'allemagne ou encore le royaume-uni se
sont réunis à nouveau dans la capitale
autrichienne
l'objectif ramener l'iran dans le giron
de l'accord et réintégrer les états unis
en retrait depuis 2018 sous l'impulsion
de donald trump et sa campagne de
pression maximale
le retour de washington une option
envisageable pour l'iran à une condition
si les états unis viennent avec la
suppression des sanctions la véritable
suppression des sanctions ils peuvent
certainement recevoir le ticket pour
revenir dans la salle des négociations
de l'accord nucléaire sinon ils
continueront à rester en dehors de la
table des négociations
la levée des sanctions un chantage selon
naftali bennett le premier ministre
israélien a appelle à ne pas céder face
à téhéran
un régime aussi meurtriers ne devrait
pas être récompensé malgré les
violations iranienne et la sape des
inspections nucléaire l'iran sera la
table des négociations à vienne et
certains penseront qu'ils méritent que
les sanctions à son encontre soient
levés et que des centaines de milliards
de dollars soient versés directement
dans leurs régimes pourris ils ont tort
l'iran ne mérite aucune récompense aucun
accord et aucun allègement des sanctions
en échange de sa brutalité j'en appelle
à nos alliés dans le monde entier ne
cédez pas au chantage nucléaire de
l'iran
une position partagée au moins en partie
par la chef de la diplomatie britannique
qui déclarent travailler d'arrache-pied
contre le programme nucléaire iranien de
son côté enrique mora diplomate européen
rassure je suis convaincu que nous
pouvons faire des choses importantes au
cours des prochaines semaines et il ya
un sentiment d'urgence à placer le
programme nucléaire iranien sous la
surveillance transparente de la
communauté internationale
les discussions qui ont débuté ce lundi
à vienne constitue le septième cycle de
pourparlers depuis avril dernier et on
va plus loin avec l'eau de lenche maison
notre expert en relations
internationales bonsoir coque blanche
maison merci d'être avec toi on l'a vu
par les diplomates sont pas vraiment
pessimiste et l'espoir de sauver la
corde de 2015 semblent minces
pourquoi selon vous aujourd'hui même
parce que le nouveau gouvernement
iranien est évidemment plus dur que le
précédent c'est sûr des conservateurs et
le négociateur donc avec les
instructions du guide suprême arrive est
arrivé aujourd'hui à vienne et on voit
bien que sur plusieurs points la
position c'est un peu durcies il fait
dans le fond à préalable à lever les
sanctions économiques de toutes les
sanctions économiques même celles qui
ont été prises sans relation avec la
sphère nucléaire et il y en a à droit de
l'homme et autres et aussi il dit dans
le fond l'iran s'est fait avoir une fois
puisque le principal partenaire les
etats-unis sont sortis de l'accord on
veut pas que ça recommence par
conséquent veut un mécanisme de garantie
que les états unis ne ressortiront pas
de l'accord lors des prochaines
élections hoog un mouvement de mauvaise
humeur du congrès et ça évidemment c'est
impossible de lui et de lui de lui et de
lui accorder par conséquent les choses
sont tout à fait sérieux d'autant plus
que bien entendu là les iraniens ne
veulent pas aller au delà de l'accord
2015 et quand on leur demande ce qu'on
fera de ce qu'ils ont enrichi au delà du
pourcentage magique de 3 67% ce qu'ils
ont enrichi à 20% à 60% se rapprochant
du seuil fatidique de 90% qui lui est le
salut militaire eh bien ils ne répondent
pas aurait effectivement ils ne peuvent
pas garder ce qu'ils ont enrichi parce
que les états unis des sorties de
l'accord alors justement les états unis
parlons-en parce que joe biden a tout de
même fait du retour à l'accord sur le
nucléaire la première priorité de sa
politique extérieure au moyen-orient on
s'en souvient pourtant washington n'est
pas représenté dans les discussions à
vienne comment interpréter cette
curieuse absence c'est assez logique
parce que ça fait 40 ans que les états
unis n'ont pas de relations
diplomatiques avec l'iran par conséquent
c'est un petit peu difficile d'être à
une table de négociation avec un pays
qu'on ne reconnaît pas dans avec lequel
on n'a aucune relation de diplomates
hier et pourtant le retour celle à
priori mais en effet ils sont dans une
ce dans un hôtel voisin de l'autre côté
de la rue
et les représentants de l'europe sont
chargés d'être les go between de faire
la navette entre les etats-unis et
l'iran est en effet le précédent
ministre des affaires étrangères iranien
avait une assez jolie expression en dix
ans dans le fond ça sera aux européens
d'organiser la chorégraphie c'est à dire
le parallélisme entre le rythme de levée
des sanctions économiques et le rythme
auquel le l'iran devra appliquer les
clauses
limitant sa capacité nucléaire telle
qu'elle figure dans l'accord de 2015
cette chorégraphie n'a pas vraiment été
établi et actuellement le nouveau
représentant de l'iran ne parle pas
exactement le même langage alors
justement l'ambition des européens et
des américains est revu à la baisse 1 on
s'en rend bien compte 110 âge
aujourd'hui un accord un petit peu
intermédiaire qu'est-ce qu'il peut
contenir cet accord effectivement on
parle beaucoup d'un accord intérimaire
qui pourrait avoir une validité de
quelques années parce qu'après tout
c'est mieux d'avoir un accord
intérimaire que rien du tout s'il n'y a
rien du tout l'iran se dotera de la
bombe dans les deux ans c'est sûr et
certain
israël de l'acceptera pas et ça peut
déclencher un conflit majeur par
conséquent c'est mieux d'avoir un accord
intérimaire qui dit intérimaire dit que
la négociation continue qu'on continue
de parler sur les sujets qui ne sont pas
traités par l'accord comme le balistique
comme les actions déstabilisatrices de
l'iran dans les pays voisins et que même
sur les questions qui sont dans l'accord
on peut en effet continuer la discussion
je crois que la chine va pousser
beaucoup dans ce sens probablement la
russie aussi la chine a des intérêts
économiques importants elle achète du
pétrole d'ailleurs
en contravention avec les sanctions mais
elle n'est pas la seule la turquie fait
la même chose l'un d'eux fait la même
chose c'est toléré parce qu'il faut bien
qu'ils achètent leur pétrole quelque
part et par ailleurs la chine voudrait
dans les deux ou trois ans qui viennent
faire entrer le
téhéran dans le groupe de coopération de
shanghai dans l'organisation de
coopération de shanghai ocs qui réunit
à certain nombre de pays asiatiques mais
aussi la russie et les pays d'asie
centrale par conséquent la chine aurait
besoin d'un répit et sur épis pourrait
lui être fournies par un accord
intérimaire et pour les occidentaux
c'est aussi une moins mauvaise solution
que l'absence d'un accord alors
justement absence d'accord on voit que
c'est tendu vous l'avez très bien
expliqué téhéran en tout cas se dit
plutôt déterminé à trouver cet accord à
vienne on sait que depuis 2010 9 ils se
sont considérablement a franchi les
restrictions imposées à son programme
nucléaire quelles sont les limites de
cette stratégie ran yens selon vous la
priorité iranienne c'est d'obtenir la
levée des sanctions économiques alors
aujourd'hui effectivement ils ont une
demande maximum qu'il a levé en
préalable de toutes les sanctions
économiques même celles qui n'ont pas de
rapport avec le programme nucléaire
je peux imaginer que dans un accord
intérimaire il est levée progressive des
sanctions économiques et comme le disait
le précédent ministre des affaires
étrangères une sorte de chorégraphie de
parallélisme établi entre cette levée
des sanctions économiques et le fait que
l'iran revienne
respecte à nouveau les contraintes qui
lui sont imposées par l'accord de 2015
donc ça je pense que c'est possible pour
ce qui est de l'uranium qui a été
enrichie en contradiction avec l'accord
depuis 2010 8 depuis que les américains
sont sortis et bien on peut imaginer que
c'est uranium enrichi soient stockées
dans un pays tiers par exemple la russie
on en a déjà parlé c'est une possibilité
mais en effet aucune raison que l'iran
bénéficient de ce gain d'aubaine c'est à
dire d'uranium enrichi à un degré
supérieur à ce qui figure dans l'accord
parce que sous prétexte que les
américains se sont retirés de la cote
merci beaucoup claude havelange faisons
nous avoir apporté vos explications
et dans le reste de l'actualité
internationale cette réunion ce week-end
au qatar entre talibans et représentants
de l'union européenne les islamistes se
sont engagés à permettre le départ de
ceux qui le souhaitent il demande l'aide
de bruxelles pour le fonctionnement des
aéroports en afghanistan un pays
également plus que jamais en proie au
terrorisme pour combattre le groupe
djihadiste l'état islamique au corps
henson les talibans s'appuie sur une
unité d'élite reportage à kaboul de
notre envoyé spécial antoine claireaux
les talibans ce n'est pas seulement des
hommes barbus vêtus du costume
traditionnel avec une vieille
kalachnikov en bandoulière cite
également la badri 313 l'unité d'élite
des forces talibanes les effectifs se
trouve dans la quasi-totalité des 34
provinces d'afghanistan est partout dieu
merci ils accomplissent avec distinction
leur devoir sacré bien et rapidement des
missions qui leur sont confiées la
principale différence qui saute aux yeux
c'est la façon dont ils sont habillés
avec du matériel de pointe
empruntés aux troupes us lors de leur
départ d'afghanistan et auprès de
l'armée afghane trei casque gilet
pare-balles fusil m16 mais aussi parfois
lunettes à vision nocturne un équipement
à l'occidentale pour ces soldats d'élite
d'une discipline à toute épreuve l'unité
badri 313 qui tire son nom de la
première bataille victorieuse des arabes
musulmans est devenu le symbole da
savoir faire militaire inédit pour les
talibans
le personnel militaire de l'unité badri
à une formation professionnelle comme
l'histoire l'a montré qu'ils sont prêts
à accomplir toutes les tâches qui leur
sont assignées nous voulons atteindre
pire des tâches similaires à celles par
exemple des forces aériennes ou des
troupes aéroportées de telles unités
doit être créée en alsace
la mission principale de ce bataillon
bien c'est assurer la sécurité de
l'aéroport mais pas seulement il peut
également se déplacer dans le centre
ville de kaboul et établir des jackpots
des barrages pour contrôler les
véhicules en quelques minutes la
démonstration les fêtes et les véhicules
et conducteurs commence être fouillés
par les soldats de la batterie 313 c'est
sur un checkpoint comme celui ci dans le
centre de kaboul qu'il ya trois semaines
une patrouille a été visé à la grenade
résultat une fusillade qui a fait
plusieurs morts et blessés
l'objectif principal de ce groupe de
soldats d'élite et de mettre au pas la
menace du groupe terroriste état
islamique en afghanistan et d'après leur
chef c'est quasiment chose faite
il a affronté d'âge de manière très
organisée il a obtenu des victoires et a
désorganisé son commandement désormais
des chenaux représente pas un seul
groupe soudé il a en outre plus de
commandement unique et si à certains
endroits une certaine menace de la part
de neige persistent la batterie et
d'autres formations militaires de
l'émirat islamique sont parfaitement
prête à faire face à cette menace vous
le voyez chaque jour nous organisons et
menons des opérations spéciales et
bientôt vous serez témoin de
l'élimination complète de cette menace
de quoi faire oublier que l'unité
d'élite avant la prise de pouvoir des
talibans s'étaient surtout signalés par
des attaques sanglantes et des attentats
violents outre leur combat contre les
terroristes de l'état islamique leur
mission est dorénavant de garantir le
calme et la sécurité à travers le pays
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
à nos parlements de la course aux
parrainages à la proche de la
présidentielle les maires ruraux sont
pris d'assaut en ce moment notre
rubrique qu'en pensent les français nous
irons à la rencontre de l'un d'entre eux
reste elle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la peuplent
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du public il
est clair que tout le monde attend saft
est ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend vous soyez déçu l'univers
uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï pj les jeunes
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est des gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l oblique
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts dit
sur la bbc une surveillance des hôpitaux
visés et il était nulle part est ce
qu'on peut vivre malgré cette douleur
quand j'ai écrit à la fois je souffrais
parce que ça me rappelait des beaux
souvenirs avec stéphane et en même temps
c'était très douloureux et puis
aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu que ça
permettait d'extraire de de moi même
toute cette histoire est donc ça m'a
apporté un peu de recul un peu
d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
et
le maintien de l'ordre une doctrine qui
est à la fois saluée dans le monde on
entend souvent parler d'excellence
française elle est aussi critiquée ces
dernières années quand on observe le
maintien de l'ordre en france au cours
du 20e siècle et début du 21e il ya
extrêmement peu de victimes
même si mort au maintien de l'ordre et
une catastrophe est tout à fait
déplorable on a vu des personnes
gravement blessées on a entendu aussi le
terme violences policières ce débat sur
les violences policières à ce qu'il a
toujours existé il a toujours existé ou
la première grande manifestation
parisienne du 6 février 34 on a même pu
craindre la disparition de la toute
jeune garde républicaine mobile dans la
presse s'était déchaînée sur ce qui
était réellement le noyau dur du
dispositif de maintien d'ordre à
l'époque
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
où
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
il est 21h merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire lettre qui met des coups de
téléphone à répétition les maires ruraux
sont pris d'assaut en ce moment à la
proche de la présidentielle certains
parlent même de harcèlement face aux
demandes de parrainage dans notre
rubrique en pensent les français nous
allons la rencontre ce soir de l'un
d'entre eux témoignage dans un instant
du maire sans expliquer de l'ému non
loin de metz nous confiera ses doutes
justement face à ces parrainages
[Musique]
et cinq mois de la présidentielle les
candidats potentiels accélère donc la
cadence pour obtenir leur fameux
précieux parrainage on vous rappelle
qu'il faut à 500 signatures pour
participer à l'élection certains maires
ruraux parle même de harcèlement noyé
sous les e-mails les lettres et autres
coups de fil dans notre rubrique en
pensent les français nous allons donc à
la rencontre d'hervé sans air le maire
sans étiquette de l'ému d'un petit
village d'à peine 500 40 hama située
près de metz reportage signé sébastien
dufour avec nadège abderrazak
nous sommes devant la mairie de lemieux
petit village de 540 habitants près de
metz pour y rencontrer le maire de la
ville hervé censeurs
[Musique]
bonjour
bienvenue à la mairie le mur
monsieur le maire vous faites partie des
maires qui sont sollicités à quelques
mois de l'élection présidentielle pour
votre précieux parrainage c'est l'une
des conditions pour un candidat on pour
se présenter au scrutin suprême
décrocher 500 parrainages de maires
c'est quelque chose qui vous dérange
vous le problème c'est que ces personnes
là ils viennent nous voir une fois tous
les cinq ans nous dans nos petites
communes on a besoin d'avoir des
personnes qui s'occupent de nos
problèmes de tous les jours et pas
quelqu'un qui vient une fois tous les
cinq ans nous dire voilà nous on a le
meilleur candidat on a si on a ça et ça
dérange beaucoup et puis quand vous
parrainer une personne vous parlez aussi
en contrepartie un parti politique et
quand vous êtes élu dans une petite
commune comme nous de 500 habitants sans
étiquette vous pouvez pas dire
je parraine du pont du rang par rapport
à son parti politique c'est ça va pas
comment cela se traduit ce harcèlement
dont parle de très nombreux maires à ce
que c'est le cas de votre côté ce que
vous parlez de harcèlement déjà
vis-à-vis de ses équipes de campagne de
ses futurs éventuels candidats bon on va
dire c'est du harcèlement mais du petit
harcèlement parce que les gens ils nous
appellent soit par téléphone soit ils
nous envoient des mails où il se déplace
en mairie ils envoyaient des jeunes des
personnes pour venir avec leurs
documents pour expliquer leur programme
ils veulent que vous les parrainer que
vous signez lors leur bulletin de
parrainage mais voilà j'en ai eu l'autre
fois et on l'a pas fait vous nous
montrez le genre de mails que vous
recevez donc là où c'est un parrainage
de monsieur vincent de la vie et ils
l'annoncent bien monsieur hervé censeurs
maire de l''onu donc il nous met tout
son programme et si on veut on peut
répondre
en signant le parrainage j'en ai reçu un
hôte par exemple de monsieur jean
lassalle bon et lui ça fait déjà
plusieurs fois qui se présente est
pareil mais tous sont programmés et
après vous pouvez donc on peut cliquer
puis se met je souhaite parrainer jean
lassalle est ce qui vous font des
promesses ces futurs candidats vous
dites il ne pense qu'à nous une fois
tous les cinq ans mais ils vous
promettent des choses au moment où ils
vous démarche je pense qu'ils sont comme
tous nos grands politiques ils
promettent des choses avant les
élections dès que les élections sont
arrivés qui sont élus ap ben vous pouvez
pas faire toujours ce que vous proposez
ou ce que vous souhaitez parce que il ya
ce qui gère la france est aussi l'argent
et puis beaucoup d'autres choses c'est
l'europe donc on peut avoir des idées
mais on peut pas toujours les mettre en
avant on y va oui
cette condition des 500 parrainages de
maires ou d'élus vous diriez que c'est
en plus que c'est un moins qu'il
faudrait la conserver ou la retirer à
pour moi il faudrait la supprimer
carrément parce que les petits candidats
comme vous et moi donc on n'aura jamais
nos 500 signatures donc il en faudrait
beaucoup moins parce que vous vous
n'avez pas les mêmes idées qu'un grand
candidat donc vous pouvez pas tout le
monde peut pas vous soutenir et puis on
a chaque maire a le droit un parrainage
qu'on peut pas parrainer plusieurs
candidats donc alors monsieur le maire
vous avez parrainer un candidat en 2012
et depuis vous le regrettez vous nous
dites plus jamais pourquoi ben parce que
quand vous parrainez un candidat les
personnes du village qui pensent que
vous parrainez un parti politique et
nous dans nos petites communes on est
élu sans parti politique et mon équipe
municipale ne voudrais pas qu'on parle
de partis de droite de gauche de
n'importe quelle partie parce qu'après
on vous met une étiquette sur le dos et
on pense que vous avez que vous votez ce
parti on va dire c'était quelques l
étiquette quel genre de partie c'était
un parti d'un stream d'extrême droite à
l'époque donc voila et vous faites une
fois une erreur dans votre vie vous la
fait pas d'eux quels ont été les retours
des habitants qu'est ce qu'on vous a dit
ben il ya quelques habitants qui
pensaient que je voter
l'extrême droite et pourtant c'était pas
le cas donc voilà donc après dans nos
petites communes il faut pas parler
politique autrement vous êtes mort on va
dire et pour les candidats connus du
grand public les parrainages ne sont
qu'une formalité pour les autres moins
connus c'est un véritable parcours du
combattant alors parrainage le système
est-il archaïque c'est la question qu'on
vous a posé qu'on vous pose toujours
d'ailleurs sur le conte télégramme verte
et france vous pouvez toujours réagir et
c'est l'objet de notre face à face
avec nous pour en parler pierre
fred-lille billets mer et l'air de dreux
bonsoir faire frédéric merci d'être avec
nous sur ce plateau
également denis ci explique porte parole
des amis d'eric zemmour est responsable
justement des parrainages bonsoir à vous
merci d'être avec nous alors première
question pierre frédéric billet vous est
harcelé entre guillemets à l'image de ce
maire de les mid ça doit être encore
pire puisque dreux c'est encore plus
grand
ah non non je ne suis pas seul nous
raison très simple si je suis encarté
chez les aînés et tout le monde sait que
j'irai parrainer le candidat des
républicains book je suis pas du tout à
celui des tentatives gentilly plutôt à
bika j'étais au congrès des maires très
récemment et quelques candidats que j'ai
pu rencontrer ici là non jean lassalle
m'ont dit toute l'amitié qui me portait
à l'occasion de cette demande de
parrainage mais voilà c'est sympathique
mais moi ya pas trop de difficultés
alors le maire de limoux d'un nous
décrit quand même son malaise il
aimerait bien parrainer un ou plusieurs
candidats d'ailleurs mais il ne veut
surtout pas on comprend être associés
aux partis politiques de la personne
qu'ils parrainent puisque il dit en gros
parrainage égale associations partis
politiques il dit que ce serait mal vu
de ses administrés d'ailleurs ça a été
le cas à l'époque on va justement voir
une première réaction télégramme qui est
en rapport avec cela celle de sébastien
regarder ces bassins qui nous dit c'est
surtout la levée
anonymat qui perturbe les parrainages de
nietzsche et smic ça c'est un vrai
danger notamment peut-être pour le
candidat que vous soutenez l eczéma ou
sept associations partis politiques
associés à ce maire et les parrainages
anonyme ça aurait peut-être été un
meilleur plan pour vous oui absolument
il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont été
dites je partage tout à fait la vie de
l'internaute qui vient d'être donné le
fait que l'anonymat est était levée
c'est une loi qui a été votée à l'époque
de françois hollande est une véritable
catastrophe démocratique et vraiment je
pèse mes mots on est dans une situation
où il ya des candidats à 4 % dans les
sondages qui sont absolument certain
d'avoir leurs promesses de parrainages
et d'en avoir trois quatre mille benoît
hamon avait je crois quatre mille
promesses de parrainages et 4000
parrainage effectif avant la
présidentielle et d'autres qui sont à 15
16% et sans jugement de valeur
d'ailleurs sur les idées en tant que tel
mais qui représente donc quelque chose
qui ne sont pas assurés d'avoir ses
promesses de parrainages d'avoir ces
parrainages et donc de pouvoir concourir
je pense qu'on arrive à une limite de ce
système il est évidemment bon qu'il y
ait une limite donnée par l'état qu'il y
ait un contrôle pour éviter les
candidatures fantaisistes mais la levée
de l'anonymat c'est quelque part la mort
d'une partie de notre démocratie parce
que beaucoup de maires aujourd'hui ses
cendres sous pression et le témoignage
était très très bien le témoigne le
témoignage du maire qui a parlé dans le
sujet précédent qui explique très bien
qu'il a peur des réactions de ces que
ses administrés éventuellement parfois
même de menaces sur les subventions ce
sont des choses qu'on voit sur le
terrain de menaces d'exclus du jour ni
partie donc la levée de l'anonymat pour
moi c'est une très mauvaise nouvelle et
pour la démocratie française aussi
pierre frédéric billet c'est vrai que ça
favorise plutôt les les parties dont
vous faites partie les républicains mais
que pensez vous de ce que vient de dire
monsieur ci explique c'est vrai que les
petits candidats il ya un problème quand
même de démocratie quand on s'imagine
que marine le pen jean-luc mélenchon ou
eric zemmour je vais pas vous faire
voilà le calcul de ce qu'ils
représentent dans les sondages mais
quand même ça pèse assez lourd à eux
trois ils sont même pas sûrs d'avoir
leur parrainage est-ce que vous adhérez
il n'y a pas un problème démocratique
comme le dit monsieur si oui alors deux
points de précisions ce n'est pas un
parrainage site une présentation du
candidat donc c'est pas parce qu'on fait
un parrainage que vous soutenez le
candidat vous pouvez présenter un
candidat dans le cadre de virer la
diversité démocratique qu'a pluralité
puisse exprimer ça c'est la première
chose à point précis des aussi est ce
que monsieur disait est un peu inexactes
en fait l'anonymat n'a pas été levée par
les neiges jospin en réalité avant il y
avait un tirage au sort des 500 nour qui
était publié dans le journal officiel
maintenant l'intégralité
voilà
et donc c'est l'intégralité maintenant
qui est publié avant il y avait un
tirage au sort il y avait 500 donc été
tiré au sort pas candidat et qui était
publié donc c'est vrai que ça va changer
un petit peu la donne maintenant il faut
voir aussi que les maires par m de moins
en moins on est passé de 34 me l'a 36 à
2 36 milliards 34 me dans cinq ans il ya
une dégradation
parce que les maires ruraux n'ont pas
forcément toujours peur de prendre
position mais simplement ils se sentent
un peu abandonné quand vous êtes maire
d'un village de 500 habitants dans la
corrèze
heureusement qu'elle sous préfet dans le
coin qui essaie de faire ce qu'il peut
mais globalement ils se sentent
délaissés dont quand vous voyez des
candidats m'ont a vu lors des déjeuners
mort venir chez nous voir u2 des maires
ruraux possible des poussées bon des
fois ils pensent comme eux mais oui ils
veulent pas s'afficher sans délaisser et
puis ils ont l'impression que l'équipe
de zemmour disent qu'ils entendent tous
les cinq ans tous les six ans et que
voilà il ya une sorte de lassitude
maintenant la question qu'il faut se
poser c'est comment peut-on faire
respirer notre démocratie plus
facilement pour des candidats sérieux
voilà donc il ya eu des réformes
proposées il ya le comité balladur qui
en 2007 a fait des propositions là
dessus le comité jose parle qui avait
fait aussi des propositions pour passer
d'un parrainage d'élus aménage citoyens
c'est pas inintéressant faut en parler
mais ce qui est certain c'est qu'il faut
renouveler cet accès à la présidentielle
on a toujours autant de candidats depuis
74 ans nés entre 12 et 16 candidats donc
ça respire mais certains politiques ont
des grosses difficultés pour l'emploi
des doges justement vous parlez de ce
parrainage citoyen proposé par la
commission jose cas en 2012 bastien la
chaux de la france a soumises aimerait
bien le revoir en être la revoir net
cette proposition mais il dit emmanuel
macron lui préfère que les candidatures
soient filtrées par les élus et par les
banques parce que d'une certaine manière
ça c'est moi qu'elle rajoute mais enfin
ça les arrange est ce que vous êtes
d'accord de nice y explique avec le fait
que voilà les grands partis notamment
emmanuel macron n'a pas nécessairement
intérêts
avoir les parrainages devenir tout
simplement citoyen en tout cas ce qui
est certain c'est que je vais répondre
immédiatement votre question mais je
partage ce que vient de dire monsieur le
maire le le parrainage c'est d'abord et
avant tout une présentation donc c'est
un acte citoyen et démocratique que
chacun doit pouvoir comprendre et à ce
titre il ne doit pas être considérée
comme un soutien mais je voyais bien que
c'est le cas sur le terrain mais du coup
j'espère que monsieur le maire va faire
jouer son sens démocratique comme son
candidat aurait nécessairement les
parrainages en parrainant la candidature
d'eric zemmour boutade mise à part sur
les parrainages citoyens
plus qu'un autre parce que il est
essentiel que tous ces candidats que
vous avez cités est d'ailleurs voyez moi
je soutiens eric zemmour mais je
trouverais ça proprement scandaleux que
jean luc mélenchon marine le pen
n'obtiennent pas leur parrainage il
représente quelque chose dans la vie
politique française on peut être
d'accord on peut ne pas être d'accord
mais il faut qu'ils puissent se
soumettre au suffrage des français
vraiment je crois que c'est fondamental
et donc je ne suis pas convaincu que le
parrainage citoyen qui pour les contours
en plus sont très peu déterminée soit
nécessairement la solution en revanche
imaginer revenir ou en tout cas arrivé
parce que monsieur le maire avait raison
c'est un système qui n'a jamais
véritablement été appliquée un système
de parrainage de 500 pourquoi pas même
600 signatures mais avec un anonymat qui
soit pleinement garantis je crois que ce
serait un bon moyen de garder pour les
mères cette prérogative qui est
importante qui est la leur c'est pas la
peine de leur retirer des prérogatives
supplémentaires
ils ont déjà beaucoup souffert pendant
ce quinquennat mais aussi un moyen de
faire en sorte qu'ils puissent sans
avoir peur des pressions notamment
subventions ce que je trouve proprement
scandaleux par une équipe de souhaite
alors évidemment la question que je
brûle dans vis de vous poser depuis
d'ailleurs le début de ce débat est ce
que eric zemmour il les a séparés nage
c'est 500 parrainages non alors à
laquelle je parle nous n'avons pas réuni
500 promesses de parrainages d'autant
plus qu'en réalité on parle de 500
promesses mais il faut 700 ou 800
promesses pour s'assurer d'avoir les 500
parrainages puisque certains maires
peuvent signer une promesse et ne pas
renvoyer au conseil constitutionnel
le document qui à lui seul une valeur
juridique donc nous n'avons pas à
l'heure actuelle 500 promesses de
parrainages et encore moins 700 vous
l'avez compris en revanche nous sommes
plutôt confiants alors à laquelle je
parle sur le fait que nous pourrons les
obtenir mais pour cela quelle gabegie
d'énergie il faut mettre en place une
machine structurellement
organisée avec des centaines et des
centaines de personnes sur le terrain
avec des cellules de phoning c'est c'est
une gabegie d'énergie qui pourrait je
crois être mise ailleurs pierre frédéric
est votre sentiment quand vous entendez
notre responsable des parrainages d'eric
zemmour voilà nos gars c'est pas sûr
qu'ils les aient alors on sait que
marine le pen dit la même chose ça fait
plusieurs élections maintenant
votre sentiment là-dessus
oui alors techniquement faut aussi
expliquer qu'on a des promesses de
parrainages et qu'en fait les
parrainages peut être envoyé dix
semaines avant le premier tour et
quelques semaines avant avant le premier
tour où l'on sait c'est une lettre assez
courte donc c'est pour ça que souvent on
prévoit plus de parrainage parce qu'il
ya de la perte olic ça c'est la première
chose la seconde chose effectivement on
peut se poser la question des
parrainages parce qu'il a faim on évolue
là dessus en même temps il faut
comprendre que les parrainages en charge
clonage c'est aussi la découverte des
territoires de france c'est aussi
l'occasion de mettre des comités en
place d'aller voir les maires même si
des fois herald en découvrant de voir
quelqu'un de discuter etc et puis je me
souviens dans le passé que la famille le
pen avait largement utilisé cet argument
pour faire de la boue c'est dire que
voilà pour sauver la france les des
parrainages et qu'ils étaient contre le
système etc c'est une vieille ficelle je
dis pas que monsieur zemmour fait ça
parce que voilà mais en tout cas c'est
aussi l'occasion de mettre la lumière
sur un candidat c'est ça qui empêche
eric zemmour justement de se présenter
officiellement pour l'instant au
contraire comme le dit afin d'aiguiller
il profite de cette tribune est et de
cet éclairage est l'occasion de se
mettre en avant non je crois pas
monsieur zemmour
prend les décisions qu'il veut prendre
tout seul et je crois pas que les
parrainages j'ai eu un impact quelconque
sur la date de candidature qui l'a
arrêté en revanche ce qui est certain
c'est que ce sera dimanche
toute façon au point où on en est que ce
soit demain mercredi ou dimanche on est
dans une zone restreinte on sait que
c'est pour très bientôt on a tous
beaucoup
patienter je peux vous dire que c'est
pour bientôt je viens là pas le jour
même non je pense que eric zemmour il il
ne joue pas particulièrement de cet
argument d'ailleurs nous on a commencé à
s'activer avant même que lui est une
implication quelconque dans la campagne
c'est à dire que nous on a monté une
structure pour rechercher les
parrainages qui après c'est vraiment
professionnaliser qui est montée en
compétence qui à qui et qui est vraiment
devenu à la hauteur d'une campagne
présidentielle sans qu'eric zemmour
n'intervienne alors maintenant c'est un
peu un peu différent il est au courant
de nos avancées il est au courant de la
démarche mais je ne crois pas que ce
soit ça qui est un impact sur la date de
candidature maintenant maintenant je
voudrais vraiment solennellement faire
un appel à tous les maires qui nous
écoutent pas rennais qui vous voulez
pour de préférence eric zemmour
parrainer qui vous voulez mais parrainer
c'est vraiment un acte citoyen je pense
que tous les citoyens même si parfois
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué peuvent
comprendre qu est un acte démocratique
de parrainer on présente un candidat on
ne décide pas de voter pour lui on le
présentait donc tous ceux qui veulent
nous soutenir et qui soutiennent notre
démarche peuvent aller sur le site les
amis d'eric zemmour point fr onglet
paris en tout cas eric zemmour ce n'est
pas le seul
ramé pour ces candidatures il y en a un
autre un nicolas dupont aignan qui a du
mal à trouver c'est signatures comme il
ya cinq ans d'ailleurs je vous propose
d'écouter le patron de débouler france
très clairement j'ai fait un appel
solennel au maire aujourd'hui je peux
manquer les 500 parrainages à quelques
signatures près je ne voudrais pas finir
à 480 et au jour d'aujourd'hui je le dis
très clairement s'il n'y a pas un
soutien à parrainage des maires je
risque de ne pas pouvoir être candidat
bon voilà il y en a des appels ce soir
pierre frédéric billet vous pas de
problème du côté lr évidemment il ya un
ancrage d'élus locaux assez
impressionnante il facilite la récolte
des signatures vous préfériez pas vous
justement donné le parrainage un petit
candidat dont on vient de parler plutôt
que d'assurer le coup pour l'un des des
poulains dont on connaît pas encore le
nom d'ailleurs un chez les républicains
oui oui c'est quelque chose c'est une
question exposer simplement vous savez
bien public 1 c'est le parti qui a la
plus grande assise territoriale sur
notre territoire les on a beaucoup à
gagner beaucoup d'élections en
renouveler nos présidents de région les
élections municipales ont été un beau
succès donc il est vrai que les
parrainages des républicains c'est aussi
une grande force pour notre candidat ça
montre que tous les territoires de
france sont représentées et moi très
engagé auprès des candidats et pour la
future présidentielle je trouvais bon
ménage ou candidat ou à la candidate des
républicains vous auriez plutôt intérêt
quand même à ce qu'eric zemmour puisse
finalement se présenter n'est ce pas ce
qui aurait peut-être le mérite de beats
diluer certaines voix à droite et de
voir peut-être un nouveau poulain au
second tour n'est ce pas
on peut imaginer des quads pour gronder
stratégie bien sûr tous à tous est dans
les tuyaux simplement quelqu'un déjà ce
stade on n'est pas déjà dans ses
stratégies tout de même que sérieusement
oui oui certainement mais si vous voulez
on veut bien que monsieur dupont-aignan
a beaucoup de difficultés parce qu'on
les aurait été mis en concurrence avec
eric zemmour avec madame le pen et la
course aux parrainages devient plus
compliqué parce que il ya un nouvel
acteur sur le terrain qui
soglo n'est pas si loin politiquement
qui représente quelque chose et donc
d'un des parrainages se disperser entre
ces trois candidats pourrait en rajouter
d'autres d'ailleurs donc ça complexifie
la chose maintenant je pense que eric
zemmour de s'il est le candidat dans les
prochains jours peut-être demain il aura
ses parrainages c'est une difficulté en
plus mais je pense qu'il les aura parce
que au bout du compte souvenons nous des
présentes élections il ya des mères qui
ont mené leur parrainage au dernier
moment parce qu'il voulait que tel ou
tel candidat puisse même s'ils n'étaient
pas d'accord avec lui pouvoir pouvoir se
présenter aux élections donc c'est
difficile c'est compliqué quand on se
lance dans une telle campagne qu'on ait
un tout nouveau candidat et qu'on n'a
pas de parti politique derrière soi
c'est difficile mais je le répète ça m'a
permis aussi de se frotter au terrain de
voir un peu ce qu'est ce que la france
parce que vu pareil c'est une chose mais
vu du territoire et des fois d'humilier
rue valmont envoyer très très loin
de nier que clairement d'accord avec
cette analyse c'est vrai qu'à une
dispersion peut-être entre des candidats
qui se ressemblent vous êtes d'accord
avec ça il ya évidemment du fait déjà
que seuls 30 % des mères en moyenne par
une fois que ces 35 % aux dernières
présidentielles et les prévisions sont
en baisse pour celle ci 1 un vivier de
par un potentiel qui est déjà restreint
ajoutez à ça le fait que les grands
candidats en tout cas les candidats deux
grands partis même s'ils sont des petits
candidats parfois dans les sondages
obtiennent trois à quatre mille
signatures ça restreint grandement le
champ oui il y as je pense une
concurrence dans les trois candidatures
dit du corps national entre madame le
pen monsieur dupont-aignan et monsieur
zemmour sur le terrain des parrainages
mais qui a donné lieu et c'est
intéressant d'ailleurs à une notion que
j'ai construite que que vous n'avez pas
idée dont je n'avais pas idée c'est la
notion de parrainage utile c'est le vote
utile mais le parrainage utile je n'en
avais jamais entendu parler il ya
beaucoup de mères qui me disent bas moi
j'ai toujours parrainé marine le pen
mais cette fois ci je pense que monsieur
zemmour est mieux placé pour gagner et
donc c'est à lui que je vais donner ma
signature est donc cette cette notion de
stratégie dans les parrainages elle est
bien prise en compte par les élus que
nous avons d'ailleurs un grand plaisir à
les rencontrer sur le terrain même si
nous préférerions que leur anonymat soit
préservé et puis à ferrer et le mot de
la fin il faut la réformer 7 il faut le
réformer ce système de parrainage salon
c'était certainement qu'il faut réformer
c'est maintenant qu'il faut imaginer
mais c'est sa s'accompagnera d'autres
réformes certainement aussi sur le poids
de l'assemblée nationale il ya un vrai
sujet nature ou à que l'assemblée en
train d'écrire en terme d'affluence ça
devient de plus en plus une salle
d'enregistrement peut-être un
rééquilibrage entre le présent
république et des ministres bref il ya
du pain sur la planche après les
élections présidentielles et notamment
les parrainages ou le système d'accès à
l'élection suprême il faudra déménager
tout ça très fortement merci en tout cas
tous les deux pierre frédéric billets
adonis et c'est d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france
ix avant de refermer cette émission
s'intéresse à alerte lancée aujourd'hui
par la défenseure des droits des droits
sur la gestion des foules de
protestataires en france pour claire et
dont un face à face tendu s'est
installée ces dernières années entre les
policiers et les manifestants un rapport
publié alors que la nouvelle doctrine du
maintien de l'ordre doit être présenté
sous peu les explications de katia
technique
clairet dont la nouvelle défenseur des
droits livre ce lundi 29 novembre une
étude sur la philosophie du maintien de
l'ordre en france en particulier dans sa
dimension confrontation elle son titre d
escalade de la violence et gestion des
foules de protestataires
l'étude a été menée en interrogeant
gendarmerie et police and an après le
début des gilet jaune a noté la
préfecture de police de paris n'a pas
voulu participer à cette étude elle
rappelle qu'après les manifestations de
mai 68 une relative pacification du
maintien de l'ordre en france s'étaient
développées mais depuis quelques années
il en va tout autrement
les chercheurs de l'étude soulignent le
tour pris par le traitement médiatique
des manifestations les manifestants se
plaignent de tactique de maintien de
l'ordre et de l' usage de la force
tandis que les forces de sécurité
cherche à légitimer leur action et
s'agace de la multiplication des
observateurs de manifestations ou de
journalistes citoyens ou non le tout
dans une logique de face à face il note
aussi un tournant là d'issia risation
des manifestations les interpellations
il remarque également que le recours aux
forces locales de sécurité
habitué aux interpellations individuelle
est insuffisamment formés aux situations
de maintien de l'ordre peuvent aboutir à
une inadéquation se traduisant souvent
par la mise en danger des manifestants
et c'est cette logique de confrontation
parfois violente qui est interrogé par
cette étude la défenseure des droits en
veut pour preuve les exercices
d'entraînement des forces de sécurité
dans des villes artificielles en france
elle met directement en scène des
situations de danger et d' escalade
exagérées note le rapport tandis qu'en
allemagne eh bien il ya également des
simulations de manifestations violentes
mais aussi de rassemblement calme où se
développe l'art du dialogue et de la
désescalade car nos voisins européens
honteux tenter de réfléchir à la
pacification du maintien de l'ordre en
2010 la police suédoise a lancé un
projet européen go diack auquel ont
participé dix pays comme le royaume-uni
l'espagne le portugal
l'objectif rétablir le dialogue la
communication lors des manifestations
les français nous ont malheureusement
pas assisté le projet met l'accent sur
l'adaptation de l'action policière au
public manifestants ils doivent
faciliter leur expression communiquer
avec les membres de la foule et ne
réprime et que les éléments violents
bien entendu il ne s'agit que de
principe sur le papier parfois
difficiles à adapter sur le terrain mais
la nasse les lacrymogènes et autres l bd
ne sont pas des figures imposées
particulièrement dans le nord de
l'europe et l'étude note que la belgique
tente d'adopter ce schéma de désescalade
en privilégiant le dialogue la
concertation la responsabilisation la
coordination et la gestion de crise le
maintien de l'ordre est ramené à sa
mission de prévention et
d'accompagnement des manifestations avec
un objectif le rapprochement dans les
relations entre la police et la
population
le schéma national du maintien de
l'ordre propose en france à l'automne
2020 ensuite amendé sera bientôt
représenter mais la défenseure des
droits note qu'il reste dans la logique
de confrontation avec une gestion et
réactive voire brutale des événements
que l'on tient pour susceptibles
d'engendrer des désordres je cite le
contraste avec les leçons que les pays
du réseau go diack ou la belgique ont
tiré des épisodes altermondialistes du
début des années 2000 reste notable
conclut l'étude le troisième
anniversaire des gilet jaune est aussi
l'occasion de montrer à quel point cette
logique de confrontation a occasionné
des dégâts durables tant physiques que
symbolique et c'est la fin de cette
émission rendez vous dès demain 20
heures d'ici là n'oubliez pas de réagir
de commenter sur le télégramme verte et
france l'actualité continue toute la
soirée
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent en soi vient de
grignan aujourd'hui on a une gauche
extrêmement
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview